During this week's
battle on the House floor
over the nust-pass defense spending bill,
there was an amendment to prohibit
the Defense Department
from requiring diversity training.
The amendment offered by Arizona
Republican Congressman
Eli Crane, was under debate
when this happened.
My amendment has nothing to do
with whether or not colored
people or black people
or anybody can serve.
It has nothing to do with, Mr.
Speaker,
any of that stuff.
I'd like to be recognized
to have the words colored people stricken
from the record.
I find it offensive
and very inappropriate.
That rebuke came from Ohio Congresswoman
Joyce Beatty.
And then Crater Crane,
we should say, later apologized
and offered this
when he said
in a heated floor
debate on my amendment
that would prohibit
discrimination on the color of one's skin
in the armed forces.
I misspoke.
Every one of us is made
in the image of God and created equal
Quote from the congressman there.
Joining us now
with more on this to Nevada
Congressman Steve Horsford,
a Democrat and chair
of the Congressional Black Caucus.
Congressman, thanks
so much for being with us.
What did you make?
I mean,
first, the congressman from Arizona
making that remark on the House floor
during this
debate over the defense
authorization bill, appropriation bill,
and then his apology afterwards.
What did you make of all of that?
What's going on
Well, Jim, thank you for having me on.
I'm here in Orlando, Florida,
at a democracy for the people
I've been
talking to, constituents
with the Congressional Black
Caucus Institute
about the issues that matter,
from voting rights
to the courts, to our schools.
But what that member
did, Representative Crane from
Arizona, was unbecoming.
It was unprofessional.
It was insensitive.
The word itself has vestiges of racism.
For that word
to be used on the House floor in 20, 23
is unconscionable.
While he may have publicly acknowledged
his error, he still has not
personally apologized
to the member,
Representative Joyce Beatty,
that it was directed towards or the body.
And look,
Representative Crane and people
like Senator
Tuberville
have proven time and time again
why the importance of diversity, equity
and inclusion training
is actually needed in this moment
as Secretary
Lloyd Austin
said of the Department of Defense.
Our diversity is our strength.
We have over 40% of our service members
who are individuals of color.
And so to have this resource within
the Pentagon
is something
that is important to our service members.
And important to our national security.
And it's unfortunate
that the extreme faction
of the Republican Congress
chose to use this as a wedge issue.
Against our military.
And I mean,
do you accept the congressman's apology
Well, he hasn't
given that
apology directly to the body
or to the member that it was targeted to.
But the larger point is it's
not about any one individual.
It's about the vestiges of why
they are using woke as a wedge issue.
Look, if you if you're against
people of color
being in the military, just say it.
If you're against us
having representation
in the private sector, just say it.
But it's time out for using these issues
to divide us
rather than to bring us together
as a nation.
Well, and you mentioned
Republican Senator Tommy
Tuberville of Alabama
and what he was saying
earlier on in the week
when he was defending the use of the term
white
nationalism and
I was talking to one
of your Democratic colleagues
in the previous hour,
and I was asking her
and I'll ask you the same question,
whether or not
these these two episodes
highlight some of the
that perhaps
the American people aren't aware of,
that there are
these kinds of attitudes
floating around up on Capitol Hill, more
so than we realize.
What's your sense of that?
Senator Tuberville
is using a Jim Crow
era tradition of the Senate,
which is a blue slip to
to uphold the confirmation of hundreds,
hundreds of military nominees
who are essential
to our national security.
These are highly qualified people.
These are people who should be
in their position.
It's the first time in 164 years
that the Marine Corps
has not had a commandant confirmed
by the Senate.
We currently have an acting person
in that role.
Unfortunately,
this is why the Congressional Black
Caucus had to call on Chairman Durbin
to reform the blue slip process,
not only for the military,
but for federal judges
and other important positions, because
it's it's past time.
It's long past time
for these types of traditions.
Which have a history in segregation
and Jim Crow
to still be
used in
the United States Senate in 20, 23.
We've called for that to be to end
or to be drastically reformed.
And we're hoping
that Chairman Durbin will take us up
on that that request
and this defense bill has been described
as dead on arrival in the Senate.
But it goes to the Senate where Democrats
are expected to strip out
these HOT-Button issues
that were attached to it.
And still has to go back to the House.
And I guess I'm curious
if some of those provisions
somehow are left in the legislation
coming out of the Senate,
coming back to the House.
Is there any chance
that you would vote for that other
do you think
the vast majority of Democrats
would have any hope
of supporting that piece of legislation?
Or might we end up in a situation
where this defense spending
bill is really
just held up for months on end
because of these kinds of attachments,
these kinds of amendments
that have been added to it?
Yeah.
Not only
are they trying to defund
diversity, equity and inclusion,
but they're denying service members
access to reproductive justice, service
members who do not have a choice
in where they're deployed.
And if they happen to be deployed
to a state
like Florida,
where I am at today
with Representative Maxwell or Texas,
where they're
now trying to take these rights away.
Those servicemembers don't have a choice.
So, yes,
the Senate
does have to act to correct
these most extreme provisions
that now have been advanced.
It's unfortunate
that Speaker
McCarthy allowed the far right faction
to take over this bill.
This is the first time, Jim,
that I've not been able
to vote for the National Defense
Authorization Act.
I have
for military installations
in my district in Nevada.
I support providing
funding to our military and
their ability to have the resource
as an the tools,
but not when it includes
these wedge issues
that are against people's
fundamental right to health care,
reproductive justice,
or that defund and erode
diversity and equity, which is a strength
within our military, not a weakness
And I want to get your thoughts on
some new reporting
that we have over here at CNN,
that secretaries of state in Pennsylvania
and New Mexico have testified
to that special counsel,
a grand jury investigating
Trump's actions after the 2020 election.
What did you make of that?
I know Nevada was another state
that had the issue
of fraudulently lectures,
phony electors
being advanced to try to overturn
the election results.
That was something that you encountered
in your state.
I guess
what is your sense of how this
this investigation
is proceeding over there
at the Justice Department?
Well, I want to commend
the attorney general
and the special prosecutor
for doing their job.
But this is why we're here.
In Orlando,
having a forum with constituents
to talk about the attacks on democracy.
This is not only about
the former president
and those who were involved in
overturning a duly elected election
or to deny the voters
the results of that election.
By over by Biden,
by not upholding the electoral process.
You know,
I was there on January 6th
at the US Capitol.
It was not just
an attack on our building.
It was an attack on the foundations
of our democracy, which are our schools.
It's the courts.
And it's the most important
and most fundamental right,
which is our right to vote.
That's why
the Congressional Black Caucus,
our members
are working to pass the voting.
John Lewis Voting Rights Enhancement Act.
It's the first time in 40 years
that Republicans have not worked with us
to reauthorize that.
These are the cornerstones
of our democracy.
We'll be talking
to constituents here later
about what
they have, their role
and their power
in ensuring that we continue
to uphold our democracy.
At a time
that it's under attack,
not just the last election,
but the elections to come.
All right, Congressman Steve Horsford,
thanks very much for your time.
We appreciate it.
Thank you for having me.